NARRATOR: Veterans of both
World War II and the Vietnam War
risked their lives
for their country,
but the way they were
treated by both the US
government and their
fellow citizens
could not have been
more different.
A lot of that had to
do with why they were
fighting in the first place.
On December 7, 1941, Japan
waged a surprise attack
on Pearl Harbor.
The US declared war
on Japan, and it
didn't take much to
convince the nation
to rally around the cause.
The sudden criminal attacks
perpetrated by the Japanese
in the Pacific
have treacherously
violated the long-standing
peace between us.
NARRATOR: And when Japan's
ally, Nazi Germany,
declared war on
the US days later,
World War II took on the larger
goal of fighting fascism.
Though there was a draft,
thousands voluntarily
enlisted to fight, some
even lying about their age
or illnesses to get in.
The reasons for US involvement
in Vietnam were a bit murkier.
At the height of the Cold
War, America's leaders
were determined to stop
the spread of communism,
so they threw their support
behind the South Vietnamese
to prevent a takeover
by the Communist north.
But unlike World War
II, there wasn't even
a formal declaration of war,
and the majority of Americans
weren't concerned with the
affairs of the Vietnamese.
But President Lyndon B
Jonson and the powers that
be wanted a win
against communism,
so the US escalated
involvement, sending over
2 million troops to Vietnam
throughout the course
of nearly a decade.
In contrast to World War II,
many potential Vietnam recruits
actively avoided the draft--
Muhammad Ali one of the
most famous examples.
Hell no, we won't go.
NARRATOR: Support for
the troops at home
also reflected the nation's
attitudes toward the two wars.
World War II propaganda urged
Americans to aid the troops
abroad in any way they could.
Civilians donated scrap metal
and rubber for equipment,
rationed food and gasoline, and
even grew fruits and vegetables
in so-called victory gardens.
During the Vietnam War, the mood
at home was downright hostile.
Vietnam was the first
televised conflict.
Footage and photos
beamed every ugly detail
directly into American homes.
Atrocities against
women and children,
drug use, and chemical warfare.
The images sparked a massive
anti-war movement that demanded
American troops come home.
[shouting]
NARRATOR: And here's
where the experience
of World War II and Vietnam
veterans diverged the most--
the homecomings.
When Japan surrendered in
1945 and World War II ended,
victorious soldiers
arrived home to ticker
tape parades and emotional
reunions with loved ones.
After nearly 10 years
of fighting in Vietnam,
the cost and casualties proved
too much for America to bear.
The US finally withdrew
in 1973, and South Vietnam
fell to the Communist
North two years later.
It was America's
first major defeat,
and the troops bore
the brunt of this loss
when they returned home.
Many recalled being spat
upon, or called baby killers.
Others felt ostracized
as scapegoats
for an unwinnable war rife
with dishonorable conduct.
And this led to another
stark difference--
the way veterans were
treated by the system
after returning home.
When World War II
soldiers came home,
the Veterans
Administration offered them
generous education benefits,
and a monthly living
stipend under the GI Bill.
In contrast, Vietnam
veterans often
had trouble receiving
enough compensation
to cover their living
and educational expenses.
Bureaucracy, red
tape, and cutbacks
led many to avoid
the VA altogether.
It wasn't until the 1980s that
America began to make things
right with Vietnam veterans.
A crucial step was
the 1982 dedication
of the Vietnam Veterans
Memorial in Washington, DC.
The late '70s and
'80s also saw a rise
in movies portraying the horror
and heroism of the Vietnam War.
While many films
about World War II
served as propaganda to
reinforce its necessity,
movies about Vietnam
were more ambivalent
and reflective, and often
from the perspective
of surviving veterans.
The box office successes
of films such as "Platoon"
and "Born On The 4th of July"
signaled that Americans were
finally coming to understand
and appreciate the men and women
who served in Vietnam.